i want to show you guys this story from  the daily news because it's kind of  silly but it's also kind of freaky  hardee's seizes on mike lindell's fbi  drama to sell pillowy biscuits  no joke  the fast food chain what is this hardy  har har thanks daily news fast food  chain hardy seized on being included in  the headlines about alleged confiscation  of mypillow's ceo mike lindell cellphone  with an ad promoting something the  bombastic businessman might enjoy  now that you know we exist you should  really try our pillowy biscuits  lindell a spirited conspiracy theorist  has worked tirelessly blah blah blah the  point here is  we're at the point  where fast food chains are making memes  of the collapse of of our country to  sell  fast food  those biscuits are a little tasteless  in my opinion  but you know i make jokes references to  gulags just kind of being  sensationalistic and hyperbolic but